alors que de jour en jour le compte à
rebours du départ pour la lune
s'approche et que les cosmonautes sont
soumis aux ultimes expérience avant
l'heure h
une information dont la portée peut être
très sérieuse vient soudain être diffusé
glenn et titoff sont tous les deux
tombés l'un dans sa baignoire l'autre au
cours d'une promenade victime
semblerait-il l'un et l'autre ne trouble
qui seraient imputables à leur vol
sidero nous avons consultés à ce propos
le docteur gérard juin experts de l'om s
en médecine aéronautique et spatiale
je crois qu'il faut être très prudent
dans cette affirmation contredit cru ces
américains s'entendent c'est beaucoup
dire et moi qui ai vus non pas les
cosmonautes russes et je le regrette
mais les cosmonautes américain est
encore tout récemment il n'y a pas de
gros problème semble-t-il et si glen est
tombé certes dans sa baignoire ce n'est
pas pour autant que les vols spatiaux en
sont responsables
et pour l'instant je pense que les
médecins de l'espace se penche surtout
attentivement sur tout ce qui peut
arriver
un cosmonaute afin de prévoir même
l'impossible même l'impensable
mais ils ne cherchent pas actuellement à
déceler tout particulièrement des
troupes de l'oreille comme on a bien
voulu le dire dans certaines dépêches
il y a eu des phénomènes certes
troublant et en particulier en ce qui
concerne le russe titeuf qui a été
malade pendant même son voyage spatial
mais il a souffert du mal de l'espace du
mal de l'air il la décrit due à une
vibration excessive de sa capsule
mais depuis lors tous ces gens s'ils
avaient eu des lésions sérieuses de
l'oreille vous ne l'auriez vu puisque on
les a aperçus de par le monde lance
promener et manifestement marchant sans
le secours de personnes et 100 de ce
cours d'eau qu'une canne
vous revenez les états unis vous y avez
rencontré des médecins de la nasa qui
suivent de très près les cosmonautes
quelle importance ont-ils attaché
justement à ce le problème de l'oreille
interne avec ses canots semi circulaire
qui préside l équilibre ont toujours été
un des sujets de prédilection parce
qu'il est évident que quand on met des
gens hors de la pesanteur dans des
positions aussi invraisemblable que cela
puisse paraître on peut penser qu'il y a
des problèmes ou qu'il y en aura donc ce
sujet est à l'ordre du jour et il y a
une semaine à peine il y avait une
conférence à l'académie de médecine
aéronautique à pensacola en floride pour
traiter de ces problèmes mais de là à
conclure que les os les cosmonautes
avait des lésions de l'oreille moyenne
qui les empêcherait de volée il ya un
grand pas que seul je crois les dépêches
sont franchies et en admettant qu' il y
ait des troubles de l'oreille interne
est ce que ces troubles serait permanent
s'il y avait des lésions véritable de
l'oreille interne comme on en rencontre
d'un certain traumatisme crânien est
très violent ou d'après certaines
déflagration come on
vu pendant la guerre il est certain que
ce pourrait être des lésions
irréversibles et que dès lors les genres
et des perturbations de l' équilibre
pour le reste de leurs jours ou tout au
moins de grande partie de ceux ci il y
as aux états unis actuellement chez un
constructeur aéronautique qui s'est
spécialisée un peu dans ce problème
un appareil d'entraînement à sortent
d'une sorte de home trainer pour
permettre aux gens de lutter contre ces
vertiges et de lutter contre ces
phénomènes dits de coriolis docteur
autant vous puissiez en préjuger quelle
est l'importance que les médecins russes
attachent à cet événement je vois que
les russes ont fourni une réponse
extrêmement valable en envoyant lors de
leur dernière expérience spatiale trois
hommes dans un véhicule dans lequel il
n'y avait qu'un cosmonautes
professionnels et de non professionnels
dont un médecin et ces gens là n'étaient
absolument pas entraîné pour être des
cosmonautes il devait certainement était
capable de remplir un certain nombre de
conditions physiques mais sans plus et
ce médecin de l'espace docteur egorov
qui a volé avec et qui a raconté depuis
leur même dans des publications
médicales ce qu'il avait observé bien
observé ni sur ses compagnons de voyage
ni sur lui même
jusqu'à présent le moindre trouble de
l'oreille et en mettant deux noms
cosmonautes professionnelle si j'ose
dire dans leur véhicule spatial c'est la
confirmation qu'ils n'ont pas de grosses
inquiétudes sur les troubles éventuels
ressentie par leurs cosmonautes